For movies as big as the ones that come out
of Disney, writers spend countless hours pouring
over every detail of their scripts to make
sure every moment is the best it can be.
However, the truth is, when the actors get
on set or in the recording booth the script
can sometimes go out the window as the stars
choose to improvise, ad-lib or just go crazy
with the character.
Often times, these unplanned moments are scrapped
but in some cases these happy accidents end
up creating some of the most amazing moments
in the film.
Here is our list of 10 Amazing Disney Movie
Moments That Happened By Accident.
Enjoy this video and be sure to subscribe
to Screen Rant for more awesome videos every
day of the week.
Be sure to hang around until the end of the
video for a special announcement!
Lion King
Many people would argue that Lion King is
Disney’s best animated movie of all time
and the truth is that there is a lot to love
about this classic film.
From the heartfelt story to the iconic characters,
every aspect of the motion picture seems to
be perfectly designed.
That being said, there is always room for
unscripted fun and that’s exactly what happened
when Nathan Lane, who famously voices Timon,
came up with the line “What do you want
me to do, dress in drag and do the hula?”
on the spot.
This line fits so well with the character
and had people of all ages laughing away and
it’s hard to believe that it was something
the actor just made up on the spot.
Beauty and the Beast
Beauty and the Beast is one of the most beloved
Disney movies of all time and the hotly anticipated
live adaptation of the classic story promises
to be a smash hit.
We have to wonder if the new film will include
one of the most famous improvised lines form
the original movie.
As it turns out, when Cogsworth’s says:
“Flowers, chocolate, promises you don’t
intend to keep,” it was actually a moment
completely improvised by the voice actor,
David Ogden Stiers.
Sir Ian Mckellen will be playing Cogsworth
in the 2017 film and we will be watching to
see if he brings back this unscripted line
and if he add in any of his own improvised
moments!
The Avengers
While most people think of animated kids movies
when they think of Disney, let’s not forget
that the mouse house is also behind the wildly
successful Marvel Cinematic Universe too!
The Avengers took the world by storm in 2012
and the movie did a great job of managing
all of the various characters and creating
one cohesive film.
That was not an easy task, especially when
you have the likes of Robert Downey Jr. messing
around on set.
Apparently, the actor would hide snacks for
himself around the set and then eat them during
and between takes.
The filmmakers tried to stop him but he persisted
and they ultimately decided to make the snacking
a fun part of the Tony Stark characters.
At this point, we aren’t really sure where
Robert Downey Jr. ends and where Iron Man
begins.
Brother Bear
Brother Bear is by no means Disney’s most
successful or famous film ever but it does
feature a pretty remarkable voice acting performance
from Joaquin Phoenix.
When a star of Phoenix’s size makes a mistake,
you just go with it and that’s exactly what
happened behind the scenes of Brother Bear.
During recording, Joaquin Phoenix accidentally
referred to Koda’s friend Bucky as Binky.
Jeremy Suarez, who voices Koda, chose to respond
by saying: “First of all, his name’s Bucky,
not Binky, and it wasn’t a pine cone it
was a pine nut!
And it was huge!
Even bigger than your fat head.”
The line is great but the writers of Brother
Bear can’t take credit for it as it was
totally made up by Suarez on the spot as a
reaction the Phoenix’s slip up.
Toy Story
With hugely talented stars like Tom Hanks
and Tim Allen voicing the lead characters,
Toy Story was destined to be a great movie.
The characters are awesome but what really
sets this animated flic apart is it’s hilarious
dialogue that can be appreciated by people
of all ages.
As it turns out, one of the most famously
hilarious scenes from the original film was
actually completely improvised by Tom Hanks.
When recording the scene where Woody is trying
to convince the other toys that Buzz is okay,
Hanks improvised the entire puppet show routine
right on the spot.
Most of the lines were so good they ended
up making it into the film proving yet again
that sometimes the best things in life are
the product of some happy accidents.
Aladdin
By this point it’s a pretty well known fact
that the late great Robin Williams did a lot
of ad-libbing and improvising for the role
of Genie in Aladdin.
There are countless celebrity impressions
in the film, but did you know the Pinocchio
gag was completely made up on the spot by
Williams.
Apparently, the filmmakers liked the joke
so much that they forced the animators to
go back to the scene and re-edit it to include
the moment where Pinocchio’s head ends up
on the genies body.
This may have seemed like a lot of work at
the time, but looking back now it was totally
worth the extra effort!
Pirates of The Caribbean
Over the years, the Pirates Of The Caribbean
movies have made an absurd amount of money
for Disney and it’s mostly due to the outstanding
performance given by Johnny Depp as Captain
Jack Sparrow.
Despite a recent string of flops, Depp is
a great actor and he brought a lot of ad-libbed
magic to the Pirates franchise.
Most notably the use of the word “savvy”
which has now become instinctively connected
to his iconic character was something that
Depp came up with on the spot and the filmmakers
decided to keep in the film.
With Depp returning for the fifth installment
in the Pirates franchise, fans can be sure
he will be bringing his famous “savvy”
line with along with him.
Guardians of The Galaxy
When you hire a hilarious comedic actor, you
are going to get improvised moments and that’s
exactly what happened when Chris Pratt landed
the lead role in the Guardians Of The Galaxy
movies.
Pratt goes off script many times in the first
film but there was one joke that he and director
James Gunn never thought would make it into
the final film.
Pratt’s character, Peter Quill, makes a
quick witted and sexually charged Jackson
Pollack reference, but the actor was sure
the joke would be deemed to Risque for the
Disney property.
However, Gunn convinced studio head Kevin
Feige to let him include the moment in a test
screening and it’s a good thing he did,
because it got the biggest laugh of the entire
film.
The Jungle Book
The Jungle Book got it’s live adaptation
in 2016 and the world got to see actors like
Bill Murray, Idris Elba and Scarlett Johansson
voicing the famous characters.
As it turns out, the original movie was almost
quite different as it almost didn’t feature
Kaa's famous song 'Trust in Me'.
As it turns out, that song was actually once
called 'Land of Sand' and it was originally
was written for Mary Poppins to sing to the
Banks children.
Disney decided that it didn’t fit in that
movie but that it was a good song nonetheless
so they just changed the name and gave it
to the hypnotic snake Kaa to sing in The Jungle
Book.
Years later, the song has become a big part
of The Jungle Book and it’s hard to imagine
what it would have been like had Disney not
made the last minute switch up.
Frozen
There is no denying that Frozen is a force
to be reckoned with and the hit song “Let
It Go” became the anthem of kids around
the world.
Kids weren’t just obsessed with the song
either, the lovable snow man Olaf, voiced
by Josh Gad, also became a huge hit with fans
of all ages.
Olaf is a pretty silly character and it turns
out that most of his lines and actions were
actually improvised by Gad while on set.
The actor has a lot of experience with comedy,
so it makes sense that he went off script
but apparently it started getting so out of
hand that the filmmakers had to reign him
in to make sure that Olaf ended up being the
character they wanted him to be and not just
and animated version of Josh Gad.
So there you have it, there is our list of
10 crazy unplanned Disney movie moments.
Which one of these happy accidents was your
favorite?
Let us know in the comments section below
and if you enjoyed this video, make sure to
check out our friends at TheTalko who made
a cool video about 10 Amazing Hidden Details
In Disney Films.
TheTalko makes highly addictive list videos
you just can’t stop watching, so while you’re
there, make sure to subscribe and leave a
comment saying ScreenRant sent you.